over the past five years I've changed a
lot like I've gone through a lot and
this is like really my first public
thing back forgive me if I'm a little
nervous
demi lovato making her first major
public appearance in over a year sitting
down with Teen Vogue editor in chief
Lindsay people's Wagner at the 2019
Teen Vogue summit in Hollywood on
Saturday where she got candid about
overcoming adversity just be yourself
and don't be afraid of what anyone's
gonna think the 27 year old revealed
that when she looks in the mirror she
sees someone that's overcome a lot
adding quote I don't see a championship
winner but I see a fighter and someone
who was going to continue to fight no
matter what is thrown in their way I
love the person that I am today she went
on to discuss her realistic approach to
loving herself a huge thing for me has
been body acceptance I feel like
something that is not really spoken
about a lot is body acceptance we hear
the terms body positivity all the time
but to be honest I don't always feel
positive about my body and for those
social media haters Demi had this to say
will let people don't realise I think is
I'm actually an extremely sensitive
person like when somebody says something
mean about me on the internet or makes a
me and making fun of me like I have a
pretty good sense of humor but when it's
at the expense of like a very serious
subject it can be really hurtful like I
am human so be easy on me and I'm so
tired of pretending like I'm not human
so let go easy on us we are humans you
know and like we as and the people that
like you're commenting about you know
what I mean you don't think we see it
what we do on a happier note I have new
music coming up
I didn't say when no I know now I'm just
teasing you I'm really teasing you it's
only okay so we don't know when that new
music is coming but the sober singer did
stress how important music is to her
genuinely I just want people to remember
that I'm a singer like I think that a
lot of the things that I've been through
have kind of outshined my successes in
the music industry or acting now and I
just want people to remember that like
that's what I want to give to the world
so please focus on that and not the
other things I've chosen this to be the
path for my life and I want to share
this music with you so that you can
listen to it when you're going through a
rough time over the summer a source told
ET that Lovato is in a really good place
after celebrating a year of sobriety
adding that she's focused on the
important things in her life like her
family friends and new music the person
I think that's most impacting me today
is my mom we've gotten really close to
over the past couple months and her
strength just continues to inspire me
every single day
[Music]